across the country ordinary Americans
from all walks of life are taking
whatever measures necessary to prepare
for what they perceive as the end of the
world
we go inside the lives of three
committed Preppers
to see if they have what it takes to
survive
this
day forever
laughs
foreign
[Music]
I wasn't born yesterday
and I've been watching and I'm waiting
because I know what's going to happen
I pray I'm wrong but I don't think I am
[Music]
the way I see it one of two things is
going to happen either the government is
going to get their head out of their ass
and they're going to implement some
serious austerity measures and they're
going to save this economy in which case
the titleists will not be getting their
checks or they're not and the economy is
going to collapse and the entitlists are
not going to get their checks and when
those people that think they're entitled
to other people's stuff don't get the
stuff given to them by the government
they're going to come and try and take
our stuff and when they do this is what
they get
I'm preparing my family for the imminent
collapse of the United States economy
a contractor in Washington state fears
that economic collapse will encourage
widespread riots and looting
and that his home in an easily
accessible neighborhood could become a
Target
we've taken steps at our house to ensure
our safety alarm video camera
guns traps but in the Doomsday scenario
that I see coming that place is not
going to be safe there's going to be
people roving in bands coming and
hitting people's houses and stuff and
when that happens I plan on being long
gone from there that's why I got my Bug
out location
it's Bug out location is a cabin d
ude undisclosed mountain range 50 miles
away
for the past year the family has
traveled there on weekends to add to
their stockpiles now a regular family
they may play their soccer games they
may go to church on the weekend we used
to do all those things now we spend our
time prepping for what we see is coming
because I believe that any rational
individual when they know what I know
would behave in a similar manner
every Monday Steve sets a prepping goal
for the family by the end of the week
Steve's wife Kim
20 year old Nick
an eight-year-old Stephen James Must ALL
help increase the stockpile of preps
which will be taken to the cabin that
weekend
this is 30 out six which is good for big
game hunting this is a 22 for you know
squirrels rabbits when it's got a 75
round drum clip on it so it holds quite
a bit and then AK-47
small nine millimeter pistol and then a
Glock 40 cal
[Applause]
you have to if it's if there's like
dirty water and and then we could purify
it
FoodSaver is a prepper's best friend
absolutely
it's not just for food either yeah it's
a 22 long rifle and we vacuum seal them
to keep them safe from moisture or other
contaminants that might be in our bunker
and so that when we go back they're safe
and sound
getting so much stuff we have to have to
dedicate a room to storing it our bug
out bags we keep here our water
filtration system the dehydrator our
canning Goods things like that I have a
feeling that medical treatment is going
to be a little bit difficult to get we
have a stapler for surgery and surgical
kits
like to keep plenty of Dental products
around this tooth right here I glued
that in about three months ago didn't
even need to go to the dentist I just
cleaned it off and
I glued it back in myself using this
product it's been good ever since get in
the back big buddy we'll bring the stuff
out to you everything stored up
throughout the week it's shipped out to
the cabin during Steve's regular weekend
bug out drills this is some fun and
games
this is something that could save our
lives
drilling now is
Staying Alive later if an economic
collapse forces them from their home
so after filling up the tank from a 55
gallon gasoline drum kept ready at all
times
to weekend bug out follows the same
procedure
first they stop at a pre-arranged
rendezvous point to hook up with Nick's
friends Nolan and Dylan we wanted to
have guys that were good with a gun so
that we could 24 7 keep somebody on
patrol to make sure no one's trying to
sneak onto the property next next they
check on several Supply caches which
Steve's hidden in the woods in case the
civil unrest he fears forces them to
hike the 50 miles to the cabin
some of the things I like to keep in the
cachet are fishing pole there's a lot of
good fishing creeks between our house
and our property a little bit of food
some Sterno heat maybe some rope
first aid kit you never know what's
going to happen
once the caches have been disguised
the group makes its Final Approach to
the cap
[Music]
the cap I placed the cabin up on the
hill
so that down below the only access is
through the road rather than enter This
Way Steve wants to maintain the element
of surprise in case violent squatters
have already occupied his cabin
so leaving the truck hidden in the woods
he sneaks up on foot along an unmarked
path behind the cabin walking in a
formation that allows the boys to
monitor the tree line for hostiles a
little bit further out
keep your eye out those trees up there
Steven James
even if the cabin is compromised Steve
believes his preps would still be safe
because he's taken a precaution to
ensure they're always secure a 14 by 14
foot concrete storage bunker it's pretty
much a blast proof door there's uh no
real way someone's going to get in here
we poured the walls and the ceiling all
in one continuous pour of concrete
there's no way that any type of an
explosive is going to breach the
structure from that direction now the
door itself it's five inches thick
reinforced concrete with 3 8 inch steel
on both sides despite the Bunker's
strength Steve has no intention of
taking Refuge inside with his props if
someone comes out here and attempts to
Salt my property We're Going to Lock and
Load and fights on I'm not hiding in no
bunker and I'm not living in no bunker
this is the place that I store my stuff
but I have no intention of living
underground that's no kind of life
once he's confident the cabin is secure
Steve goes to retrieve the truck packed
with new Preps
most weekends Steve plans an activity
for his group
but there's no fishing or roasting
marshmallows on today's agenda Steve
wants his entire team to practice their
defensive Maneuvers against his greatest
fear
in multiple Vehicles storming the
property's main entrance I've placed
rocks around that we can get behind to
use a shielding if we get into a fire
fight and we've created a Kill Zone it's
a bottleneck at the bottom of our
property
we have made plans to bury explosives
down at the bottleneck the type of
explosives that you can shoot with the
rifle and have them go off that way if
somebody does pull up an attempt to get
in through the gate we'll be able to
shoot those explosives and stop that
attack
this one is your 50 660 grain 50 BMG
armor piercing incendiary Trace around
with the red paint those are the ones
we're going to be using today
the explosive Steve's chosen to defend
his cabin is a commercially available
binary compound that's the manufacturer
recommends preparing it in half pound
batches but to be sure it can annihilate
an attacker's vehicle Steve thinks he
needs something with a little more kick
so he's mixing 80 times the recommended
amount hi sir
binary explosives start as two separate
relatively stable substances not until
they are mixed do they become a
dangerous explosive we need to flatten
out that hole a little bit down there
Steven James
but altering the recipe could have
serious unintended consequences
fearing and impending economic collapse
will result in large-scale rioting and
crime Steve H is about to test whether
or not 40 pounds of binary explosive is
enough to defend the only Road into his
bug out cabin from an armed attack when
you're faced with the reality and you
take every step possible to keep your
family safe that's a positive thing to
do and that's what we should all do
because it is coming we are a sinking
ship and you had better grab a life vest
this weekend Steve's eight-year-old son
Stephen James is also seeing action for
the first time you're gonna load it all
the way up
Steve's concerned that with two
approaches to the cabin the main road
and a rear path an invading Force might
use a pincer maneuver to attack them on
both fronts so it's Stephen James's
responsibility to take out any Targets
in back
and that gives us a cover from behind
but it would be extremely difficult to
approach this place from behind
[Music]
now Stephen James I'd like you to be
stationed over here
Nick I want you up in the Machine Gun
Nest with the 50 cal all right you're
going to take out the Truck Engine with
the 50 cal Nolan I'd like to see you
over here behind this rock when he's
above that explosive take him out got it
foreign
[Music]
there's the rear end with no axles on it
Driveline just completely sheared off
and that's what happens if you try and
come up my driveway
I think our test was a success
if somebody would have been in there
trying to get into our gate
they would have been laminated
my mother says that our prepping is a
negative influence on my eight-year-old
son hey here's what's left of the drive
line but I say it's a positive influence
on my side
reality is what reality is and the
sooner that we Face Reality the sooner
that we're going to be able to do
something about it I don't want to lose
anybody in our family I don't want
people in my family to be hungry I don't
want people in my family to be
discomforted or in pain and so I'm
taking these steps beforehand to see to
it that that doesn't happen to us
Practical Preppers has scored your preps
in five categories of 20 points each
food 14 out of 20 points water you have
access to rivers and streams but no
stored water in the event these become
contaminated 18 out of 20 points we have
a well here as well as the streams
shelter 17 out of 20 points security we
recommend installing surveillance
cameras fortifying the gate on the main
road and getting trained in defensive
measures 14 out of 20 points I think
that's a valid assessment we should seek
some other training in addition your
construction experience gives you 16 X
Factor points overall you get 79 out of
100 points you have 16 months initial
survival time I think they were
assessment is spot on especially about
the security there's a lot of things
that we can do that would be better and
uh I think I'm going to seek some
training
[Music]
it's a recession and European debt
crisis most economists believe a
near-term depression is unlikely and the
odds of a global collapse that would
result in a severe breakdown of society
are remote
David Appleton fears his home in
Charleston South Carolina could be
destroyed at any moment
for most rappers getting ready for
doomsday is no joke but for a comedian
like David even the apocalypse has a
lighter side if doomsday happens there's
a lot of things I'm not going to miss
the Kardashians when comes to his escape
plan however he fears he'll have to do
something that goes against his nature
serious
[Music]
all right ladies and gentlemen if this
your final comic of the evening his
name's David Appleton you know him as
apples
yes yes keep it going
oh you're beautiful thank you how are
you guys doing tonight
I did one girl one time maybe you know
her she's uh she was from Jersey her
name was evil Beast
and uh I'm glad she's dead
I'm kidding I'm kidding that's after the
apocalypse if doomsday happens there's a
lot of things I'm not gonna miss
um the Kardashians
anything Kardashian related TLC because
they threw out learning a long time ago
if you guys know this or not I'm
actually a prepper as well
[Laughter]
seriously I'm actually preparing for a
catastrophic earthquake to hit
Charleston South Carolina
prepping is one part of my life and it's
part of my life I take very serious
people say oh when things go bad we'll
just come to your house don't come to my
house I will shoot you in the face
I'm kidding I won't want to David
Appleton is a well-known stand-up
comedian in Charleston South Carolina
three nights a week he hits the comedy
clubs and improv joints to test out new
material twice the pleasure twice the
fun but when it comes to one part of his
act David is not kidding around having a
sense of humor at the end of the world
is is going to be pretty important
because if little things get you down
then at the end of the world you're
gonna have a really bad day
I'm prepping for an earthquake because
it's happened in the past in 1886 a
magnitude 7.3 earthquake hit Charleston
damaging nearly every building in the
city imagine every house in your
neighborhood just knocked down and now
it two years ago we had four small
earthquakes last year we had six
earthquakes they're happening more and
more that's a big indication that a
larger one is coming down the pipe
everybody says oh you'll see Humanity
will come together and when else in
Kumbaya about a campfire and take turns
rebuilding each other's houses it's
sadly I don't think human nature is
going to go that smooth eventually yes
people are going to be willing to take
your life for your supplies for your
food hey I hope that doesn't happen as
much as the next guy but if it does and
you're not prepared
sorry
David has stored enough food and water
to ride out the first 72 hours of a
massive quake
hey I built a greenhouse and they go
you're growing weed right
after that he plans to flee for a Secret
Safe House
but being a stand-up comic sometimes
makes it difficult to fund his Escape
we don't spend a whole lot of money on
prep you know sometimes you can't afford
to buy expensive preps or buy a you know
eight million dollar bunker and bury it
in your backyard if I could do that hey
that'd be great but I can't so he's
creating a cheap doomsday Rickshaw to
let him Escape quickly with whatever he
can carry I designed this it's my
creation it's used I used a very rare
material called PVC pipe 30 feet of PVC
two inch pipes a couple of connections
you know I found some of this stuff the
screws are the most expensive piece of
it I checked Craigslist ah constantly
you can see free things Phil just wants
you to pick them up and when I see
scraps or things people have thrown out
that are still useful I see an
opportunity how can I repurpose that
do you need some help yes what I want
you to do is time me putting it together
alrighty Lauren is as close to a female
version of me
as possible
a lot of crazy women in my life you can
clap for crazy women you remind me of
most of them that I dated on your mark
get set go
faster faster faster
husband David is an amazing man cannot
believe that he just took pieces of pipe
and was able to put it together into
something that was usable wow that man
is so creative coming up on one minute
it's dirty good you can carry a good bit
of weight on here the Doomsday Rickshaw
only weighs 30 pounds but can carry 200
pounds making it capable of serving as a
stretcher if either David or Lauren is
wounded in a cataclysmic quake
for now he's using it to hunt for more
free raw materials he can use to build
other economical Preps
I like to take my trailer out and find
you know if I can find scrap wood
Scavenging to me to be able to look at
your surroundings and go what can I take
from this I don't want to dig through
people's trash but I'll find something
that's that's useful and and reuse it
if a cataclysmic earthquake forces David
and Lauren to hit the road with their
belongings he wants to be able to stay
hidden while enroute to their Bug out
location
some military-grade camouflage nets can
cost hundreds of dollars
today's haul has yielded a discarded
canvas tarp and some wire mesh trash
that David thinks is perfect for making
his own camo for next to nothing
I'm making a canvas a camouflage set the
mesh over it and then we'll start out
with the darker colors and then work our
way to the lighter colors
everything has to be the same if you
wear one glove and a shot you have to
wear a glove in every shot
it's not so much uh
about covering every part of it you want
to just make lines because what you're
trying to do is break up the shape of
whatever you're trying to hide and then
once you
pull away this netting gives a nice
little grid pattern when someone looks
at it the the grid will actually kind of
fool the eyes it's not the most
beautiful thing in the world but if
you're trying to hide your preps this
will do and finish
voila
David and Lauren believed getting out of
town and away from an earthquake's
epicenter is key to survival but if
Charleston's roads are covered in rubble
or underwater they don't have a Surefire
means of Escape
so David's been stockpiling even more
junk than usual Scavenging anything he
can get his hands on to create the
ultimate Bug app vehicle for dumpster
diving Preppers
and it's no laughing matter
David Appleton is a stand-up comedian
who loves to make people laugh if you're
gonna do reality TV show remember you're
always miked
try not to fart loudly
he's also a prepper but with almost no
budget for prepping David spends trash
day driving around the neighborhood
looking for garbage he can turn into
vital preps I like to use what I have
um some say I'm a MacGyver because of my
long flowing hair and gorgeous physique
but mainly
um you know you got to use what you have
as long as roads are passable David's
plan a is to plow through the rubble in
a retrofitted 1985 army truck that he
bought online and calls the rhinox
rhinox cost me 4 500 it can pull the
gates off a hill and it's also got
Bluetooth and a hula girl it has this
big bar on the front you can hit stuff
with I had to I would so hit something
with this I would just run right to
Goose at fences whatever
but in an area surrounded by water David
fears a catastrophic Quake could leave
him trapped in a city being inundated
with water
there are three bridges that connect
this island to the mainland and any one
of them could be knocked out by an
earthquake if that happens I want to
make sure I have a way to get off and
get to where I need to go
[Applause]
so he's using his Hall of scaven's junk
to turn his parents 30 year old pontoon
boat into a prepper's escape craft
my boat is called the rafter
all goes bad I'm going to ascend those
little stairs and get on my pontoon boat
and get the hell out of here
it's really slow but it pulls a lot and
can carry an amazing amount if roads
aren't an option I can hop on the boat
and and get completely where somebody's
either gonna have to swim or have a boat
to get to me
hemmed in by an ocean and two brackish
Rivers David can't be certain how long
it will take him to find fresh water
should a massive Quake destroy
Charleston's infrastructure
so to make sure he can Harvest drinking
water whenever it rains he's using
gutters and barrels salvaged from the
side of the road to build a rain
catchment system
the rafter is uh indicative of the way I
prep because I'm using what I have
foreign
[Music]
as the rain comes off the top it'll
drain into here and then run down we
have to put a pipe here that can go down
into the actual Barrel itself
foreign
the rain will come down off the back
here
we'll spill into the uh the old gutter
that we found and then it's going to go
to this pipe here that we installed this
pipe is going to drain right down to the
bottom of this old trash can you never
know unless you try it out sounds like
here comes the rain my apocalypse plan
includes an aluminum pontoon boat
uh hopefully there will be no lightning
involved in my Doomsday
worse
thing actually worse
[Music]
someone come see what I built for you
Molly let's bug out come on
oh wow
this is Cutting Edge camouflage
technology
and you made this from all of that stuff
you collected yesterday well not the
pontoon boat part of it but pretty much
everything else
awesome on the board
it doesn't look like much sitting in the
middle of the yard but you know how much
it cost nothing high five high five you
know what I like about this room you can
really feel the crowd you can just feel
the energy comes at you and just give it
right back all right thanks guys that's
my time I'm apples thank you very much
comedy is about two things truth and
pain it doesn't take the tragedy away
but it does help you deal with it in
that moment doomsday is not funny
um sadly it's not going to be fun for
most people but some parts of it are
going to be hilarious
Preppers has scored your perhaps in five
categories of 20 points each food your
Greenhouse is not currently yielding
survival level amounts of food 8 out of
20 points we actually intend on
purchasing more long-term food storage
and Lauren is learning to can the food
that we grow right now your water preps
are excellent 15 out of 20 points
shelter you lack a sustainable shelter
at a set Bug out location 12 out of 20
points one of our Bug Out locations is
on a nearby Island and there are
sustainable shelters there but I just
don't wish to share it with you
security is a weak Lake nine out of 20
points in addition having a truck a
trailer and a pontoon boat all ready to
bug out earn you 13 X Factor coins
overall you get 57 out of 100 points you
have six months initial survival time
yeah
okay I feel it's adequate yeah after an
earthquake yeah I accept that I'll take
six months and you know what we're gonna
work on it we'll make it longer
absolutely high five
experts estimate that a magnitude 7.0 or
greater earthquake occurs in Charleston
South Carolina every 500 years with the
last occurrence in 1886 South Carolina
has experienced a number of small
earthquakes in recent years but
seismologists do not believe this
indicates a catastrophic Quake is
imminent
for the past 15 years Suzanne streisauer
has been turning 30 acres in Northern
California into a mountain Retreat rich
with food water and other resources but
lately Suzanne's All About the Benjamins
cheese brokering deals and making power
plays but she's not interested in stocks
or bonds she's planning a series of
unusual trades and if they pay off big
they could turn this peace-loving
prepper into a doomsday Tycoon
foreign
[Music]
acres in the foothills of California's
Sierra Nevada mountains
there is a secret that Suzanne
streisauer and her partner Dave have
worked hard to conceal from the rest of
humanity
thank you
after 15 years spent biting their time
they're almost ready to reveal the true
purpose behind everything they're hiding
away up on the mountain
all they need now is for the world to
end when the economy collapses I'll
barter everything I have to survive and
thrive
[Applause]
the United States is doing things that
are very unsustainable for itself and
there's such a polarization in our
Congress and and government that is
breaking right before our eyes
the United States is not going to be the
global standard for the currency anymore
I think we're going to for sure have
some kind of currency collapse where
money is not going to be worth what it
it used to be worth and I think it's
going to get worse I tell everybody
listen you need to have a plan you need
to know what you're going to do if
something comes down so it's about
mindfulness it's about preparation it's
not about fear that's why I really
advocate for people to be lifestyle
Preppers not Doomsday Preppers
Suzanne's lifestyle plan for an economic
collapse is to turn her Mountain Retreat
into a giant doomsday swap meet all her
resources will become alternate currency
she'll use to barter and trade for
whatever she needs that includes water
from her Wells and 9 000 gallon tank and
power from her solar panels and wind
turbine
I have nine hours of power stored in
these batteries right here so it's
really pretty amazing
I'm prepared to barter what I grow from
my land so that means my fruits my nuts
it could be veggies it could be eggs
from the chickens
[Music]
to make her doomsday swap made idea
sustainable Suzanne wants to start
stockpiling foods with longer shelf life
ones that will be more valuable as
barter Commodities should the economy
collapse
so she's meeting with a local farmer to
try to score some rice now this is Patty
rice or rough rice now this is what's
harvested right out of the field but you
have to take the husk off at least to
eat it and then you have brown rice
brown rice is better for you the Patty
rice will store for a long time but I've
stored it for eight years you've got me
like a truck bed here what how many
pounds are here there's about 800 pounds
of rice in here in this inedible State
Pat says his rice is value is 20 cents
per pound but once the rice is milled
something Suzanne can do herself he says
its value will jump to at least one
dollar per pound you got in a finished
form 800 worth of rice wow what would
you charge me in dollars delivered I'd
charge you 150 dollars okay does that
sound like a fair deal you've come a
waste yeah that is a fair deal okay okay
so now if they're a way I can barter
with you yeah okay talk to me at
Suzanne's doomsday swap meet she plans
to offer more than food for trade
if the country's power grid is knocked
out as a ripple effect of an economic
collapse she believes firewood and
clothing she makes from her Homespun
will be hot commodities
could be my yarn
sweaters or
full of scarves straws for you know
foods that last for months that's a
great deal I think this is one of the
best preps I could possibly have Pat
says Suzanne's 800 pounds of rice could
last eight years on a shell but much of
her other barter food will spoil long
before then if she dehydrates her fruits
vegetables and meat they'll last much
longer than they would otherwise I want
to create a dehydrator for myself there
would again be a great prep for me for
food storage but industrial size
dehydrators can cost thousands of
dollars
so for her next prep she plans to build
her own if she can barter for the raw
materials I'm gonna go into town
to uh one of the local recyclers and see
what they have available down there see
if they have anything I can use
[Music]
hello welcome how can I do for you hey
I'm looking for a refrigerator and I
want to be able to make it into a
dehydrator so I don't really want a
refrigerator I want something I can do
something else with okay so you want
like a remains a refrigerator I have a
couple over here you might be interested
in you can take a look at
it we have one here
this one's okay I want to be able to
have like meat on one side I think and
then vegetables of fruit on the other
this work really good you know the going
ready for the appliances here like
twenty five dollars so is there can you
make me any kind of deal
um what kind of deal you trying to make
what I'd like to be able to do is to
trade with you do you ever do that kind
of stuff here not not often but let me
see what you guys made we can work
something out
so these are all things from my farm and
from my land so fresh eggs
a little bit of firewood
this is actually wool doesn't that feel
good the way we do a little bit of mix
and match here like with some
eggs some oranges some lemons some herbs
or onions and then I have these little
plants tell you what I'll be willing to
give up the refrigerator
for the wood
the oranges
and the back of your precious wool
uh I think that's a lot to ask because I
probably get 50 bucks for that wheel how
about if I did a little bag of wool
the wood and then these things well you
got yourself a deal great thanks
Suzanne has already secured the Manpower
for building the dehydrator through
another barter with her neighbor Tom she
treated him supplies from her Farm in
exchange for his labor you can go and
take some of what you owe me off for
this all right if it only takes me a
couple hours I think 100 bucks off that
would be just fine with me Suzanne wants
to get the dehydrator up and running as
soon as possible
thank you
[Music]
but there's something else even more
pressing on her mind she thinks her
doomsday swap mate will be a perfect
place to bug in should the economy
collapse but that it could also be a
perfect Target for looters so she's
decided it's time to barter for an
unusual weapon most Preppers would never
consider
stop
Suzanne streisauer is a California
Native who's building a Doomsday prepper
swap meet with her life partner Dave
but she fears some visitors to her swap
meet might come to take not trade
she knows her defenses are her weakest
prep so she's visiting a local military
surplus store to investigate her options
I don't want to kill people so with that
is my starting place now what you want
less lethal right Robert suggests a stun
gun as a non-lethal defense option stun
guns can be discharged repeatedly but
they require close quarter contact if
someone is coming towards me there's no
way I want to be that close to anybody
so stun guns are completely out for me I
get it you don't want to have to hurt
somebody you don't want to have to do it
but to me
you have to be willing to accept it
willing to go with the fact that
I might have to Suzanne is steadfastly
resistant to Conventional Weapons so
Robert thinks she might respond best to
an unconventional item that kids
normally use just for fun it's one that
can cause pain but usually not permanent
damage and should at least make an
attacker hesitate giving Suzanne a
chance to retreat or call for
reinforcements you want distance
something that's going to stop somebody
what's scarier than something flying at
you paintball which is a deterrent they
they hurt they sting drop somebody to
make them think twice not just oh what
was that and where they sell the
different rounds for Credit Control two
pepper balls that actually are the same
thing as the pepper spray or you go to
the bean backgrounds neoprene Buckshot
uh rubber rubber slugs they hear the
boom they feel the impact they're going
to think I'm shot I'm gonna die I'm
wondering if you'd be willing to take
the next step and actually show that to
me and then trade you for something for
your time and effort I'll bring a couple
different types of rounds for you so you
can see the difference in stuff at the
end of that we'll work out the trade for
my services to your services that'd be
cool I'd really appreciate that
ball guns use a compressed air system to
propel ammo through the barrel of the
gun in regulated paintball games gun
velocities are not supposed to exceed
300 feet per second in a field they turn
them down to about 280. you can turn
them as high as 400 at 400 it will break
the the top layers of skin and leave red
marks bruises and hurt it will make
someone go I'm not going that direction
yeah I want to try my try all right
before you load up just any just like
any gun
you always want to make sure you're safe
you put the barrel
it's on safe nothing's in there nobody's
where we're going we'll load you up the
full thing hey what are you doing on my
property
hey stop get off get out of here
get out of here
and that's all you need a little bit of
stopping them okay so let me try
it's not a bad thing to use
remember it's all about training but
we'll do some stuff that way you can get
the full effect of the the real
Adrenaline Rush it's a real I gotta
think move go and do all at once
now we're stepping up a notch
well what I'm gonna do is see if she can
hit me when I run at her I'm gonna be
the aggressor on her to see if she can
take it you ready yeah
I'm taking it
house
okay okay I'm done I'll stop I'll stop
I know now that in all good conscience I
can go and shoot somebody with that the
best way to prepare is to get the
knowledge to do right that's what I like
about this is the knowingness to
understand this and to have experienced
it so this is good who would think the
paintball could actually be a security
prep
yeah I feel like it's creative prepping
and I think that's part of what prepping
really is about is a different mindset
to be open-minded to possibility and
opportunity as a lifestyle prepper
I'm very optimistic
Practical Preppers has scored your preps
in five categories of 20 Points each
10 out of 20 points water you have
excellent storage capacity we encourage
you to develop a filtration plan for
other sources in case your well water is
compromised 13 out of 20 points we have
ample water for you know nine thousand
gallons of water it's going to last a
long time shelter 13 out of 20 points
security while a paintball gun is
innovative you should continue to
develop your perimeter defenses 3 out of
20 points in terms of security we do
need to improve security
you know if we needed a bunker I don't
know that we'd want to stay in addition
you are a practice negotiator which will
serve you well in difficult times nine X
Factor points overall you get 48 out of
100 points you have four months initial
survival time well I think that my goal
has been met I wanted to have three
months initial survival time to last
until another growing season could
happen so I'm fine with that
I got Tom to go and finish his bartering
deal with me so he finished my
dehydrator and we tried some fruit from
the store and it turned out pretty well
so the dehydrator seems like it actually
has worked pretty well and I continue to
go and look for other things to barter
with to improve my Preps
the strong recession beginning in 2008
and European debt crisis have made some
doubtful about the future of the economy
however the odds of a global collapse
are remote
[Music]